>> Tucker: YOUR PRAYERS HAVE
BEEN ANSWERED.
IT'S TIME FOR FINAL EXAM
WHERE WE SEE WHICH NEWS
NEWS.
WE DO THAT BY PINNING THEM
SHANNON BREAM AS YOU WELL
EXAMS.
LAST WEEK SHE COMPLETED A
FULL BRADY BUNCH BEATING
CHRIS STIREWALT RUN HER
RECORD TO 9-0.
TONIGHT SHE GOES FOR TENTH
STRAIGHT WIN AGAINST
AMERICA'S NEWS HEADQUARTERS
HOST LELAND VITTERT.
A MAN FAMOUS FOR HIS NEWS
ACUTE.
>> AND HAIR.
>> Tucker: AND GENERAL GOOD
TEMPER AND GOOD LUCK TO YOU
LELAND.
>> I HAVE BEEN STUDYING TAPE
BUTTON SO IT WOULDN'T WORK.
>> WHATEVER.
>> JILLIAN.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE MORE
FEROCIOUS, LELAND AND CUT
YOU OFF THERE AND TELL YOU
YOU HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL I
FINISH ASKING IT IN ORDER TO
ANSWER.
EVERY CORRECT ANSWER IS
WORTH A POINT.
IF YOU GET IT WRONG YOU LOSE
A POINT.
>> YEAH.
>> GAME ON.
>> Tucker: FIRST ONE
TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
DONALD TRUMP WAS ASKED ABOUT
THIS.
HIS RESPONSE WAS IT A, SHE
I LIKE OPRAH, I DON'T THINK
SHE IS GOING TO RUN?
LELAND VITTERT.
>> C.
>> Tucker: C, TO THE TAPE.
>> OPRAH WOULD BE A LOT OF
FUN.
I LIKE OPRAH I DON'T THINK
SHE IS GOING TO RUN.
>> Tucker: WOW.
>> Shannon: HE IS OUT TO THE
LEAD.
>> TRYING TO PSYCH ME OUT.
>> Tucker: JOIN A LONG LIST
OF PEOPLE WHO BEGAN.
>> Shannon: HE GOT IT.
>> Tucker: CONGRATULATIONS.
QUESTION TWO ANOTHER
MULTIPLE CHOICE, THE
PRESIDENT JUST UNVEILED HIS
LATEST NICKNAME THIS TIME
FOR SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN
OF CALIFORNIA.
WHAT WAS THAT NICKNAME?
WAS IT A SLEEPY DIANE?
B, SNEAKY DIANE, C, SWAMPY
DIANE?
>> LELAND VITTERT?
>> I'M GOING WITH SNEAKY.
>> Tucker: SNEAKY DIANE, NOT
SWAMPY, SNEAKY.
NOT SLEEPY.
ROLL THE TAPE.
>> WE DO HAVE THIS TWEET
LAST HOUR.
IT WAS 20 MINUTES AGO?
THE PRESIDENT THE FACT THAT
SNEAKY DIANNE FEINSTEIN,
HERE WE GO.
LOOK OUT SLOPPY STEVE.
>> Tucker: SHE IS TRYING TO
LULL YOU.
I AGREE WITH THAT QUESTION
FEINSTEIN FOR YOU.
>> Shannon: OKAY.
>> Tucker: SHE GAVE UNUSUAL
TESTIMONY ON THE DOSSIER
WITHOUT CONSULTING ANY OF
THE CHAIRS CLUE COMMITTEE
>> Tucker: SHE DID IT BUT
SHE SAID DID I IT CAUSE LILI
I WAS OFF THAT DAY.
>> Tucker: MEDICAL ISSUE,
THAT'S OUR FIRST HINT.
IT'S SOMETHING YOU CAN CATCH
ON THE SUBWAY.
>> Shannon: NARCOLEPSY?
>> Tucker: A COLD?
LILI COLD, FLU.
WE WILL SEE IF THE TAPE
RATIFIES IT.
>> I DON'T MAKE AN EXCUSE
BUT I HAVE HAD A BAD COLD
AND MAYBE THAT SLOWED DOWN
MY MENTAL FACILITIES A
LITTLE BIT.
SHAFN SHAN THERE YOU GO LILI
>> Tucker: ANSWER WAS NOT
NARCOLEPSY.
>> Shannon: YOU CAN CATCH IT
ON THE SUBWAY.
>> Tucker: I DON'T LAUGH
ABOUT NARCOLEPSY.
LILI CAN I ASK THE RULES
HERE?
IT'S BEST OF FIVE.
>> Tucker: INCORRECT ANSWER
PUTS YOU DOWN A POINT.
HAPPEN.
WOULDN'T COUNT YOUR POINTS
UNTIL THEY ARE FINAL LILI
OKAY.
THANK YOU, PROFESSOR.
>> Tucker: ANOTHER MULTIPLE
CHOICE, AMERICANS STILL
ONE PLACE IN THE UNITED
STATES WAS COLDER THAN THE
SURFACE OF THE PLANET MARS.
WAS IT A IN THE STATE OF
NEBRASKA, FLAT AND COLD?
B IN NEW HAMPSHIRE,
MOUNTAINOUS AND COLD OR C
THE NORTHERN MOST STATE OF
THE EAST COAST MAINE?
LELAND VITTERT?
>> I SHOULDN'T HAVE DONE
THAT BASED ON THE RULES BUT
I'M GOING WITH NEW
NEW HAMPSHIRE THE ANSWER?
>> MOUNT WASHINGTON, NEW
HAMPSHIRE, IT'S SO COLD THEY
THE GUY ACTUALLY HOLDING
THOSE BUBBLES AS IF IT WAS A
BASEBALL.
IT FEELS LIKE MINUS 100.
TIED FOR THE SECOND COLDEST
WORKING ON THE WEEKENDS.
BRYAN LLENAS WAS DOING THAT
LIVE SHOT ON MY SHOW.
>> Tucker: IT'S THE TALLEST
PEAK IN NEW ENGLAND.
THIS IS UNPRESS TENTED BUT
WE STILL HAVE A QUESTION TO
>> I'M READY.
MAKING DESPERATE ATTEMPT TO
LIKE FEISTY CHERRY, THIRSTY
>> Shannon: DIET COKE.
>> Tucker: REALLY HAVE.
>> DIET COKE IS GETTING A
MAKEOVER.
YOU MAY NOTICE SOME SLIMMER
CANS THERE THEY ARE UP ON
YOUR SCREEN AND DIET COKE IS
UNVEILING SOME NEW FLAVORS.
>> Tucker: HOLY SMOKES.
THIS IS A LITTLE BIT LIKE
WHEN WINSTON CHURCHILL
YOU ARE NO NEVILLE
WAR.
>> Shannon: CAN I HAND IT
OVER?
>> Tucker: YES, YOU MAY, CAN
YOU HAND THIS IS THE COVETED
YOUR UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S OKAY.
>> Shannon: YOU NEED TO
BORROW THE OTHER NINE TO
ACCEPT TABS PEACH WRITTEN.
>> Tucker: I WAS ACTUALLY IN
THE MEN'S ROOM EARLIER.
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU, LEE
LAND VITTERT.
CONGRATULATIONS, NINE IN A
ROW.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
I'M GOING TO RETIRE NOW.
>> Shannon: NO, NO.
YOU HAVE TO GO FOR NINE NOW.